a chemical weapons attack
claims of election meddling
even threats to curb europe's energy
supplies
the scale of suspected russian
hostilities towards the uk and its
allies is growing
now a former british spy who wrote a
dossier on russia that triggered a
political earthquake in the united
states is breaking cover to speak to sky
news with a warning
there are
serious people at the top of russia
who regard themselves at war with us did
you ever uncover any evidence of hostile
russian operations against the uk
yes
it's not just britain that christopher
steele deems to be at risk from the
kremlin i think they think they could
possibly collapse
and what about his infamous dossier that
claimed donald trump and his 2016 u.s
election campaign colluded with russia
we described it as a nuclear device
ticking away in our safe
this is the boardroom
where a number of sort of orbis dramas
played out over the years
a rental office inside this building is
where the story of the british spy who
challenged an american president began
christopher steele describes himself as
a risk taker he set up orbis business
intelligence a private intelligence
company here in his hometown of farnam
with a colleague after they both left
britain's secret intelligence service
mi6
i sent the email out from this very room
to my fbi contact saying that i needed
him to come to london
asap in 2016 the men accepted a piece of
work to investigate possible links
between then-presidential candidate
donald trump and russia
[Applause]
their ultimate client was a law firm
that represented rival democrats the
result was political dynamite
it was in this
safe here that the bomb ticked he's
referring to his work on trump dubbed by
some the dirty dossier
venturing out for his first british tv
interview steele sat down with sky news
at nearby farnam castle to defend his
work and talk about the russia threat it
was single source reporting in general
it was produced
in a live sort of real-time
process
as this election campaign was unfolding
his unverified reports alleged
widespread russian interference
sanctioned by president vladimir putin
to stop hillary clinton from winning and
even that the kremlin was colluding with
the trump campaign how much of this
is real do you think
i think the vast majority of it's real
how confident are you that the content
of that truly conveyed material is
accurate
i think it's largely accurate i mean if
you were to say to me as every crossed
tee and dotted i write
the answer is probably no
that's very typical of intelligence work
what matters is that the main thrusts of
it are right
and the majority of details right what
can you say about the credibility of
your sources we were professionals we
had done this throughout our careers and
our lives and
we were pretty confident that the
majority of the sources were highly
reliable
and others were certainly moderately to
highly reliable which is a good position
to be in when you're doing intelligence
work
but trump has dismissed the dossier as a
hoax and its author as a failed spy
it's all fake news it's phony stuff
it didn't happen
the u.s government has accused russia of
interfering in the 2016 election by
hacking and leaking emails to damage
hillary clinton
but official investigations didn't prove
collusion between moscow and trump and
there's been no evidence to corroborate
steele's most lurid claim
that the kremlin holds compromising
video material of trump with prostitutes
taken when he visited a hotel in moscow
in 2013.
what level of confidence would you place
on there being sex tapes of trump taken
by russia as compromise
pretty
the former president spokeswoman says
that's nonsense it's disgusting it's
false it's an outright smear
and there's never been any evidence
because it never happened this was one
of the biggest dirtiest tricks in
politics led to the biggest smear
perhaps in american history
with no evidence completely made up to
try to derail the american people's
choice for president 2016 and hurt his
presidency and are you a fraud
no of course i'm not
what do you say to them if i'd been a
fraud do you think that i would have
held
security clearances in government for
decades
his life was turned upside down when his
dossier and identity became public in
january 2017.
steele claims he may even have been
targeted by russian agents while on
holiday with his wife curiously it was
in my wife's sponge bag
two wedding rings one male 1 female
which were planted in her sponge bag in
our bathroom in our
luxury high security hotel in the
caribbean and what do you think the
message was
we know where you are we can get to you
don't think you're
able to hide from us a spokesman for
president putin declined to comment on
any of the allegations
steele was once mi6's top kremlin expert
and he says his work on trump is only a
fraction of his work for private clients
on russia
something he's still doing and he's
worried
in the run-up to the brexit referendum
of june 2016 his company was
investigating suspected russian meddling
across europe including in the uk
did you ever uncover any evidence of
hostile russian operations against the
uk
yes everything from um corrupt
leadership money being brought onshore
and invested in strategic industries and
the like which is something of concern
to
potential attempts to fund parts of the
the brexit campaign
and interference in that
scottish referendum
um some evidence of
interference in in that as well and what
sort of evidence i don't have it to hand
but clearly some of the same playbook
that we saw so money being moved through
deniable channels and coming out the
other end technically legal
there was a whole load of loopholes
there's since been the salisbury spy
poisonings blamed on russia
evidence of meddling in the 2019 uk
general election even attempts to hack
covert vaccine research
would you describe the russia problem as
getting worse not better absolutely yes
i think it's i think russia itself is
becoming
it's moving from being an authoritarian
state to being a much more totalitarian
state so i think that we've got a real
problem
he doesn't believe his former colleagues
in the security agencies are doing
enough to deter russia neither are their
political masters
i mean there are
serious people at the top of russia
who regard themselves at war with us
and
the fact that our politicians neither
want to recognize or deal with that is a
big problem but the uk's former national
security adviser pushed back
every senior politician i've dealt with
labour conservative lib dem whatever
takes any threat of this kind really
seriously they take national security
seriously they worry about the impact on
the democratic process their right to do
so
while the united states launched
multiple investigations into russian
interference the russian government
interfered in our election in sweeping
and systematic fashion
in the uk it was just parliament's
intelligence and security committee
we know that russia targets the uk
and not just to steal secrets or
research
it suits russia if there is disunity in
the west
the watchdog found the government didn't
carry out a full investigation into the
possibility of russian meddling in the
brexit vote
it's very worrying because i think what
it shows is
because brexit was such a divisive
partisan issue if you like
that there's not an area they wanted to
tread into the government's repeatedly
said it never found evidence of
successful interference
steele claims russia also poses a risk
to eu unity
they've got to the point where i think
they think they are they've got their
tails up
um
they can think that they can work
through particularly eastern european
countries where they've got governments
which are sympathetic to them
um and extreme left and right parties in
western european countries similarly
that they could actually bring down the
eu so you really think that they believe
they could collapse the eu
i think they think they could possibly
collapse
they are zero-sum thinkers
they think that if anything benefits us
it's
their expense
if anything benefits them it's at our
expense
and that sort of mentality and
philosophy
leads to
serious problems and serious threats to
our integrity
former prime minister theresa may is a
figure singled out for particular
criticism over her response to the
russia threat
christopher steele revealed that he and
his business partner chris burrows had
briefed her on it more than a decade ago
did she take you seriously
back in 2010 yes
how do you know that well she was there
for hours i mean it's not
it's not particularly orthodox for the
home secretary to have a meeting like
he says the government had even asked
him to review some sensitive papers on
russia just days before his trump
dossier became public so found these
remarks quite galling it's absolutely
clear that the individual who produces
dossier has not worked for the uk
government for years were you surprised
at her comments
surprised and disappointed steele had
decided to share his dossier with
british officials in late 2016. he says
they handled it properly but he's not so
sure about the then prime minister
the overall impression i had was that
this was a problem they didn't want to
face up to and therefore there was a
fear i think that trump was so pumped up
with all this stuff
that if the british government was seen
to
give it credibility and to work on it
that they would have been punished
in whatever form whether it's a trade
deal or
whatever else
theresa may and others were trying to
achieve with america at the time
her then national security adviser
disagreed the british government as both
theresa may and boris johnson have said
has to have a good relationship with the
president of the united states whoever
that is
but because he didn't see action um of
the kind that he was hoping to see does
not mean it wasn't taken seriously and
any allegation of that kind is of course
investigated properly and professionally
steele also appears to have concerns
about the current prime minister i think
it's very curious that he enabled the
son of a kgb officer
indeed i do i think it's
worrying
he's referring to lord lebedev owner of
the independent and evening standard
newspapers who told sky news he's proud
to be a british citizen
the peer said he and his father have
entirely separate business interests and
he thought the uk had moved on from
obsessing about what people's fathers
did or do
putin himself once said
um
czechist
if you're an intelligence officer once
you're always an intelligence officer
and i've been surprised that the number
of
former russian intelligence officers
who are
able to come to the uk send their
children to uk
invest money in uk so on and so forth
we're not getting this right
not everyone will think he got it right
either
but steele hopes by breaking cover they
will at least hear his warnings